okay
all right
are people who don't people the people
who don't keep the sabbath will they
make it to heaven people who disobey god
will be lost
are you with me
people who willfully deliberately
fragrantly directly high-handedly
disobey god will be lost because if god
saves them sin will start all over again
so when the person says well those who
don't keep the sabbath to be lost martin
luther didn't keep the sabbath
eloise said he'd be in the kingdom
william miller didn't keep the sabbath
he was not convicted he'll be in the
kingdom during the dark ages there were
thousands and millions who knew nothing
about the sabbath because it was an age
of darkness but god knew the heart of
those people they'd be saved but when in
1844 october 22 the temple was opened
then the light of the law flashed out
all over the world so that excuse is
gone
are you with me blessed are they that do
his commandments that they may have
right this is not salvation by works
this is expressing your love through
obedience